the next steps facing Greece range from
staying in the euro to catastrophic
divorce going against his boat winning
left-wing policies three prime ministers
in grass will have to accept austerity
in exchange for loans Greece has cash or
hold on well it's government last if no
compromise is reached between the Greeks
of the European powers bailout from
store and emergency assistance is
rationed that means capital controls
which could force tsipras to backtrack
the majority of Greeks want to stay in
the euro so this could mean the start of
a new coalition involving pro-european
partners or with banks shut the
Popular's may respond badly capital
controls forced the government to print
a new currency the weakened economy
forces banks and companies to default
and the country is left in financial
limbo Greece leaves the euro in a messy
default no help is offered to support a
new currency banks and the government
collapse the new depression forces
europe back into recession